hello everyone today we have a NZ yes uh
from hugging base um who is working on
AI safety and Alignment using
reinforcement learning with human
feedback um she's an expert in the space
of large language models
and their
evaluation um before hugging face she
led a team of researchers at sales SCE
focused on building robust um natural
language generation systems based on LMS
and she got her PhD at UT Austin in
computer science so everyone
[Music]
welcome great thanks for having me uh so
the title of my talk today is recipes
for training helpful chat
Bots um so here's the introduction uh I
was part of this team called the h 4 at
hugging face and today I'll you know
walk you through what we built you know
how we decided on you know what we need
for building that and so essentially
what we wanted to build and the goal of
the team and the project since earlier
this year was to figure out a recipe for
H4 which stands for helpful harmless
honest and Huggy because it's hugging
face chatbot um and so like you know the
ingredients essentially work to like you
know figure out what kind of data sets
do we need for supervised Trine tuning
and RL
um and we wanted to like you know not
worry about pre- chaining instead take a
open- source pre- chain model and
recreate the secret source of alignment
on it um and the procedure that we
wanted to follow and replicate on open
source is this figure that I'm pretty
sure most of you are familiar with at
this point is like from this instruct
gbd paper from openi uh which shows
three steps uh I'm going to go into a
bit more detail on this because the
slide is much smaller over here uh but
this is what the outline of the talk
looks like um I'll be getting to detail
of like you know how did we decide what
kind of data how much data and all the
details of the data for supervised fine
tuning um then similarly for rlf um then
I'm going to talk about distillation of
language model alignment um then
experiments with different helpfulness
recipes finally talk about evaluation of
these models and quirks of using GPD 4
as an
evaluator okay so this is kind of like
you know what a overall recipe that
instruct gbd paper from open I put
forward as you know the steps for
training a chatbot um so the first step
over here is to do supervised
fine-tuning essentially like you know
you're doing fine tuning with human
instruction demonstration data so the
input and the output are both given by
humans the step two is like you know the
input is given by a human the output
comes from models and then the human
just rates thumbs up thumbs down or
Banks them and then you train a reward
model which is essentially just a
classifier and then the final step three
is doing fine-tuning using that reward
model with uh with reinforcement
learning um and so the way I'm looking
at is like step one is more for like you
know making a model into a helpful
chatbot and the steps two and three are
essentially trying to add those guard
rails in place for harmlessness so in
let's get started with talking about
helpfulness and most of my uh talk today
will be focused on the step one um so
the let let's start uh diving deeper
into this and let's started with like
you know the data set like how do we
decide what we need for doing the
supervised fine tuning so like you the
data set for helpfulness for supervised
fine tuning looks somewhat like this
this is from the self- instruct paper if
you aware of that from end of last year
so you have something that we call as a
task which then has an instruction which
is essentially a request by a user
asking the model model to like fulfill a
like give a response to certain task and
that follow that is followed by a input
and output the input in this case is
optional it could just be part of the
instruction um and then the output is
the expected output that the model
should generate but while we are doing
this training the human provides the
expected output that the model would
have generated in the actual test case
um and so here the input and the output
are called instance or demonstration or
completion and that's why this is called
instruction
demonstration uh so this is kind of like
just a high level landscape of what
these data sets for instruction
demonstration look like um and you must
have you know been familiar with at
least some of these um and like you know
the way I'm try to put this is on this
line where on one side I'm showing data
sets that were generated using models or
more powerful language models and so
they are more synthetic data sets on the
right I'm showing like human written
data sets and so these are model these
are uh these are data sets that the
human wrote the input as well as the
expected output and so examples of these
are like you know so the surge instruct
is the data set that we at hugging phas
H4 you know contracted with surge this
company that you know that basically had
U contracts with annotators that were
writing the inputs and outputs but we
had to give them all the specifications
of what kind of data we need um and then
you must have heard of like you
obviously open assistant is this other
CommunityWide effort where you know
people contributed manually writing
inputs and outputs similarly with Dolly
um and then on the other end you can see
like you know the self- instruct data
set I'm going to like dive into some of
these how are these synthetic data sets
created for uh for helpfulness or for
supervised fine
tuning so one of the examples of how
this synthetic data is created is in
this self- instruct paper which is
called bootstrapping the data so in this
case they start with 175 C task that is
you know a 175 like a very small uh data
set of examples where the manually
written inputs and outputs from humans
those are added to a task pool then a
language model like you know basically
you bootstrap by giving that language
giving that to the language model in a
few short setting and ask it to generate
more data like that um and then you have
another language model that does this
task classification like you know what
kind of task is this um is this sample
or example belonging to and finally it
also does this more fine grain
classification as to like you know does
it have you know output first or does it
require input first and so on and
because this is synthetic data and
created in this like a very scalable way
you also have to do a lot of filtering
to make sure that it is very high
quality so another way of generating
this kind of synthetic data is what
Ultra Chad did and in this case they had
like a human in the loop process so
human would like you know look up like
either you know search Wikipedia or
something um and then come up with you
know topics that they want to generate
data for and then you know ask the model
like provide it with the required
material that would be needed for you
know coming up with say question
answering or summarization or any of
these specific tasks um and then give it
to a more powerful model like chb gbd4
in this case it was J gbd and then or
actually gbd4 and then you kind of like
you know keep doing these Loops of like
you know giving the material to the
model and say like come up with
questions and answers of on this
particular task using all this material
and then you know then the human looks
at it and then keeps squaring it and
refining it more and more so this is
another way of creating synthetic data
obviously this has a human sitting there
and doing a lot more filtering in the
process um then there's another one
which is like even less human involved
which is role playing and this is the
camel data set uh in this case all the
you all that the human does is like come
up with an idea of what task or what you
know example they want so at a high
level it would be like develop a trading
bot for the stock market and there would
be two llms one would be role playing as
a AI assistant the other would be role
playing as a AI user and then they
basically just specify the task and like
let these two Bots chat with each other
and create a conversation data set which
is again like a synthetic data set for
supervised fine tuning
so this is kind of like you know just
going back to this you know landscape it
looks like you know there there people
have been very creative and how do we
get you know very high quality data
quickly without spending a lot of money
um and because humans are inefficient
and expensive and so these are like you
know some examples that we looked at but
on the other hand we also cannot like
you know underestimate how good quality
like the manually created data sets are
and so we at um hug phase decided to
like you know go with everything like
very manual and like you know have
humans do both the input and output also
go figure out like what are the you know
essential documents or you know other
material they need for coming up with
creating this data
set but when we started doing that we
were earlier in the year so this is back
in January or February of this year and
this is what the landscape looked like
at that time um and so there was very
little data sets available a lot of
these were mostly synthetically created
um so we wanted to like you know kind of
Leverage What was existing out there but
we also had to make some really
important decisions CU we going to like
P pay money and like make sure that the
data that we collect is actually useful
for building the model and you know the
applications that are built on top of
it so these are the learnings that we
had from the past papers that were you
know creating these supervised F data
set we knew that the data set has to be
in the range of tens of thousands of
examples so this is from the self-
instruct data said um and we also knew
that you know these U models that are
trained on this data set show
diminishing returns after just a few
thousand high quality instructions so
you don't need a lot and then it
saturates very quickly so these are the
two findings that we had when we started
to like go collect data set for
supervised F
unit um but we also had to give some
very fine grain specifications on what
we want for our data set um in
particular we had to decide what is the
task distribution we want for the data
that we are collecting I mean we know
it's tens of thousands but how many
thousand of what task right the length
distribution like you know should the
prompt have a certain length is that
even an important factor um and one
thing is that we wanted we we had
decided that we want to make it high
quality and human written but then there
were like options on that as well we
could go with external vendors like sge
scale AI AWS CR and so on or we could
hire our own contractors from upwork and
mtk and so those were like decisions
that we had to make so let's look at
each of these one by one so because we
were recreating this instruct GPT recipe
for this helpful chatbot we wanted to
like you know take inspiration from
their task distribution so on the left
I'm showing like the task distribution
that instruct gbd did for uh open ey did
for the instruct gbd paper as you can
see that generation is like you know the
majority of it uh followed by some you
know some of these open-ended tasks and
brainstorming tasks and so on and these
are examples of like what prompts of
each of those look like so we decided to
like you know just go with that but
instead you must have noticed that
there's this category called other in
their table and we obviously don't know
what that was but so we decided to
replace that with code so essentially it
would be like debugging asking quite
clarification questions about the code
it's like code plus natural language um
so this is how what our final
distribution looked
like U the second question was the
length distribution so we also had to
like you know figure out like you know
how important is the length and should
we like you know have a certain length
distribution then we ask uh these
companies to collect data for us so we
did a pilot study with s scale Ai and
AWS Sage maker Ground Road which is more
like a managed service so it's very
different from MK and they have very
high quality um human uh humans like
basically writing these examples um and
so I wanted to like just highlight that
you know this are the first rows here
show what the instruct gbd length
distribution looks like and as you can
see this is obviously the full data set
this is more like pilot so like the
counts are much smaller uh but you can
see like the maximum is uh 248 and as we
know like that's was like the standard
Contex size in the beginning of the year
um and then you know there is obviously
like even the mean and you know that
much it's not like basically it's more
or less you know in the range but if you
look at you know these examples from
surge AWS a scale AI there's very high
variance so for example AWS stage maker
the maximum prompt length is 1036 but
then like you know the mean is just
54 um and on the other hand with surge
the maximum length is 500 but then the
mean is much like you know one 104 so
it's like more in the range of what we
would expect from like you know this
difference in instruct GPD and similarly
with scale AI we found that you know
there are um promps were just very very
U short um and so just based on this we
said that you know okay we should
probably just go with search cuz you
know that seems like something that is
more um you know in the range like not
very high
variance so we ended up collecting
10,000 instruction demonstration pairs
from Serge and this is what the task
distribution looked like so this very
much follows the task distribution
instruct gbd um except for the coding
part which was like the other category
over there and these are the number of
examples we collected for each of these
tasks um and and year over year I'm
showing like you know the average length
for each of these task categories um and
one thing I wanted to highlight was
which was very surprising to me is that
the chat is actually one of the shortest
prompt length categories which but for
open AI that is actually one of the
longest prompt plan categor so uh which
was very interesting and so um obviously
like you know at that time we did not
think much about it but when we like
started training models and started
looking at the evaluation results we
were kind of like you know if had to go
back and change things how would we
change that um and so these were like
things that we started you know looking
at more carefully after we had already
collected the data
set um so here are examples of what that
data set looked like U you know
classification generation brainstorming
I'm sure you all must have seen at least
some of these kind of examples of
instruction demonstration data sets so
it's very much like it has everything
that you can expect from like NLP time
kind of task but also more open-ended
chatty um task as
well okay so here are like some details
about the task force that was used by
sege to generate this data said uh we
requested a us-based task force mainly
because we like I said we just wanted to
replicate what instruct gbd was doing
and based on anthropic and open a paper
it seemed like they they prefer going
with the us-based task force um the
gender roughly equally divided and the
age range was also very U you know very
it was like a big range going all the
way from 19 to 62 um and then people had
like you know uh education background
ranges from technical degree to PhD so
PhD was mainly for tasks like math
coding and so
on okay so now I wanted to like switch
gears a little bit and talk about this
diff this data set that we collected for
ourl or for human preferences before I
get into like you know the experiments
we ran with this supervised funing data
set and what results we
got so again over here while we were
collecting human preference data set we
had to come up with what are the
specifications of these data sets so
again just to like contrast this with
how is it different from sft the sft
data set both the input and the output
are written by humans in this case the
human writes the input the output comes
from Models which is respon respes but
then the human just ranks or rates them
on a certain
scale U so yeah essentially we had to
decide like what is the task
distribution looks like for rlf data is
it going to be same as supervised fine
tuning what about the length
distribution and should we do like
single Turn versus multi- turn so in
instruct GPT it was mainly single turn
so if we trying to replicate instruct
gbd we would have to go with single term
but if you're you know trying to
replicate something like Chad gbd it
would have to be like a multi-t dialogue
um and then we had to also like you know
decide on these dimensions of like
helpful helpfulness honesty and
harmlessness so these are like the HHH
that entropic follows like um openi puts
it as like helpfulness
trifula is individually or are they
going to rank them and what are the
implications of like you know us
deciding one way or the
other so we started by doing
um pilot study again so we we took 300
prompt from the self- instruct data set
the data set that was released end of
last year um and then you know gave it
uh generated model responses from our
models and then gave it to data vendors
to like rate the responses of the models
and we use this anthropic template on
the left which is essentially asking the
mo asking the human choose the most
helpful and honest response and then you
know these are the responses from like
Model A and model B and this is a scale
which is also working as like sort of a
ranking thing in the sense that 1 to
four is like decreasingly Model A and 5
to8 is increasingly model
B um and also like you know one other
thing we had to decide about is like how
much data should we collect um and so
again this is from the instruct GPD
paper and as you can see like you know
they have like the train and validation
splits for each of the three steps which
are the sft training the reward model
and the Poo um and this one is in the
order of tens of thousands and like over
overall this combined which is like you
know this process of rlf comes up to
about
100,000 great okay so then once we got
this pilot study data back we sat down
and we wanted to also like you know so I
looked at it manually and I felt that I
did not agree with most of the answers
that you know the annotators from each
of these companies were providing and so
I was kind of like you know I don't
think this is high quality at all uh so
what I decided is like you know I told
my team let's go and like you know rate
it within ourselves and then you know we
we basically rated like about 100
examples or so um and we followed like a
similar template of like 1 to 4 and 5
to8 and it basically the output like you
know the takeaway was that even we did
not agree amongst each other so
essentially like our models earlier in
the year were so bad you were
essentially breaking tag like
arbitrarily like you know you're
deciding between like should it be like
you know three versus like seven or
something like that so if they're
equally bad it's hard to like decide
which one is better right and so we were
kind of like breaking some of these ties
arbitrarily and so uh as you can see
like you know there was barely any like
you know agreement or correlation among
our outputs and then you know when I
aggregated that and you know looked at
you know how well do we correlate with
like for for example Surge and scale and
so we decided like you know scale AI we
had like more um like the maximum
overlap was with scale compared to like
say
surge okay so we ended up collecting
20,000 dialog so we decided to go with
multi-turn um and so we want because it
was multi-turn you would have like
20,000 overall dialogues but the number
of prompts would be 880,000 so there
would be each dialogue would have about
four turns on an average so like you
know a human would prompted the model
would respond a human would like rate
the response and then you know ask the
follow-up question and then again the
model would like you know generate two
responses and that is how it would go on
um and so the task distribution we
decided to follow was um a little bit
different from what we had for
supervised fine tuning um and the reason
behind that was that we wanted to focus
more on tasks that were like factual so
that uh you know essentially this is
more about making the model learn like
between positive and negative signals so
making the model like discriminate
between between like you know what is
facture what is not what is helpful what
is not and what is harmless and what is
not um and like you know for for example
task like generation and brainstorming
there's no one correct answer like you
know everyone can come up with like
different list or recipes and you know
it's hard to say is this the best answer
is the most helpful answer but if you
ask like a factual question it's like
very clear what is correct and what is
not um so that was kind of like a
reasoning behind doing this um and so
this is a task distribution that we came
up with for collecting the human
reference data
set also about the length because we are
doing this in a multi- setting and so we
wanted to make sure like you know the
entire dialogue could fit into like the
context line of the models we have
decided to like you know ask them to
keep the overall dialogue to be shorter
than
248 uh tokens um and then it was multi-
turn with an average of four turns per
dialogue um then obviously we had to
also select on the dimension of like
whether we are going for like helpful
over harmless or you know honesty so we
followed this instructions from this
openi guidelines I'm not sure if I can
pull this up that would be
nice okay
great but yeah so open AI has this um
document which is public of like
labeling instructions that they shared
with their annotators um and so they
have obviously like I said they have
helpful truthful and harmless but then
they also have this thing how do I
scroll down okay
so they have definitions on what does
what do they mean by helpfulness what do
they mean by truthfulness and what do
they mean by harmlessness so in our case
because our models were not as good we
decided to focus on helpfulness and
truthfulness and when they had to break
ties open AI says that you know choose
truthfulness over helpfulness over your
so like let me see that where is
that um
yeah so they wanted to like prioritize
harmlessness and truthfulness over
helpfulness but we went with the other
way around we said we wanted to like
prioritize helpfulness over honesty or
harmlessness because I mean we weren't
even focusing on harmlessness because we
just wanted to get a model to a certain
capabilities before we start thinking
about that uh but yeah this is really a
very good document and like you know
defines what should the annotator be
looking at and how do they decide um
when the moral responses are very close
how do they break those
dieses um and for like you know deciding
between what kind of template should be
use for an collecting these annotations
we started off with anthropic template
that I showed few slides earlier which
was on a scale of 1 to8 but essentially
ranking between these two models and
then you know llama 2 came out while we
were in this iterative process and our
iterative process was essentially we
used to give a end point to the V Ender
and then the you know the basically the
annotators that they had in the man
managed task force would prompt these
endpoints the model would respond two
response would generate two responses
they would you know follow the
instructions and you know give the
ranking for each of those instruction
each of those model responses and then
you know again like follow up with the
second prompt and the conversation would
go on and then they would give us the
data at the end of that week we would
fine tune a model on that data so that
the model now is hopefully better and
then we give like a better endpoint to
them for the next week to continue this
process so it's like very iterative and
like you know they have to adapt to like
model getting better week by
week um so yeah basically but like you
know we decided to switch to I think for
one or two weeks we collected and
Tropics um use anthropic scale for
collecting data set uh but then llama 2
came out and their results showed that
you know clearly that that you know they
were using this much more easier scale
of just one to four uh so they were like
you know um choosing which one is a
better response between the two
responses and then saying how much
better it is so is it like significantly
better or is it only slightly better and
so that that was the ranking of like
scale one to four um so here are
examples of data that we collected so on
the left you can see that it is asking
about like you know basically human
human is prompting with a question and
then the B generates a response and then
so this is the response that the human
chose at this turn and then the human
you follows up with the second prompt
and then this is the bot response that
was chosen by this human and this is the
rejected bot response and this is giving
the response margin of three which is
saying that they are quite a bit
different so four is like very different
and one being very slightly
different and then here on the right
hand side is more about sort of
generation brainstorming kind of a
example where in the human is asking
like can you write a text message
wishing their husband a happy
anniversary and then the bot writes
something um I guess my thing messed up
the Emojis but um you know then the
human follows up with saying hey you
missed this important detail which is
you know they have been married for
eight years and so this is a chosen bot
response this is the rejected one that
the human you know chose between those
two and as you can see they are quite
good so the response margin is just one
so they're like just slightly
different okay sounds good uh so now I'm
going to like talk about this another
recipe that we tried which is you know
using synthetic data set essentially for
distillation of AI alignment which is
basically the paper that we released
last week called zeper and which was
like a seven billion parameter model
which actually beat Chad GPT and this
Builds on top of the mile model uh but I
just wanted to like you know yeah just
you know basically we recreated some of
the steps that were there on the
instruct gbd paper but now with using
synthetic data set um and and so the
first one is like you know you you are
basically like using a data set in this
case we use ultra chat so this is a data
set I showed a few slides earlier for
supervised fine tuning where in like a
human was brainstorming and like
Gathering the material and then play
like you know chatting with this gbd4
model to like generate uh multiple
different you know outputs for the
instruction and then you know this is
how we collect that data set which is
called the ultra chat um and then we use
that for fine-tuning our model and then
the second step is the response
generation AI ranking so in this case
also like you know we used uh Ultra
feedback which is a data set that was
released and the way this data set was
uh was constructed was that you know
they asked U basically like you know
took some prompts from like share GPD
and some of these different data sets of
sft that were already out there and then
they gave it to four different models
like four different powerful models like
Palm 2 claw 2 GPD 4 and so uh and so on
and then they asked this gb4 to like
rank which one is rank each of those
four responses and then so like you know
the one that is the best is the one that
gbd4 ranks as the highest so each of
these are scored individually on a scale
of 1 to 10 and the one that gets the
maximum score is like the best
response and then finally we did we did
something called DPO which um you might
have been aware of came out of Stanford
is like this kind of alternative to rlf
which is like doing this direct
preference optimization and so instead
of like you know um basically doing this
iterative process of fine tuning you
directly like optimize on like the
chosen one so we just take that and then
um find tuna model directly on that uh
chosen response and the other one that
we are using is like a random response
from these other three
responses um okay so I'm going to uh
talk a little bit about experiments and
evaluation for each of these recipes one
is collecting everything thing with like
humans involved and the second one is
everything which is synthetic um but
then before I discuss evaluation I
wanted to talk about like what are the
benchmarks that we are evaluating on and
how good are these benchmarks for
evaluating chat Bots um and to think
about evaluation we need to First think
about how are we training these models
so like today all the models that are
trained are like more or less have these
four ways of learning the first one is
pre- training the language model
essentially are predicting the next
token and examples of these are like
gpt3 op and so like the foundation
models um the second type of learning is
in context learning or the prompt based
learning um in this case you're like
just giving a new kind of task in the
context of the model and then you know
ask it to like you know do that on new
examples so like you know if you wanted
to write a poem for example for GB3 you
would like have written that in the
context and then it would have generated
new poem on some other
topic uh the third type of uh learning
is the supervised fine-tuning um which
was kind of like the first step of
training a chatbot in this case you're
like fine-tuning on the instruction
following data and then you want these
language models which are just
pre-trained to predict the next token to
become chatty and to like generate
open-ended responses um and then finally
the fourth one is reinforcement learning
from Human feedback which is nud nudging
the language model towards the values
you desire and examples include llama to
chat from
meta um so the first two steps are you
know we have a lot of benchmarks for
these two types of training like Sanford
Helm is an example of that or the Google
big bench or even hugging faces open llm
leaderboard uh but for the for these two
types of uh learning which is supervised
fine tuning and reinforcement learning
from Human feedback which are parts of
like this recipe for training or chatbot
there's you know not a lot of
leaderboards or evaluation benchmarks
available but there are some available
and I wanted to to like you know just
highlight some of
those so like yeah this is essentially
like the steps three and four year match
to like you know the step one over here
which is helpfulness and then steps two
and three over here which is like you
know nudging the model towards U being
more
harmless so if you had to you know
evaluate the chat bot for each of these
steps you would have to think about how
do you evaluate instruction following a
chattiness you would have to EV you know
think about how do you evaluate the
reward model which is essentially a
classifier and then finally think about
you know how do you evaluate for
harmlessness which is by red caming or
adversary prompting the uh the language
model um so for the first step you would
have to see like does the model generate
useful responses on the topic and are
they open-ended and one example of a
prompt that you would try to evaluate
the model would be to like know save
brainstorm a list of the New Year's
resolution um and so examples of uh
benchmarks and evaluation boards that
are that are looking at this sort of
like supervis finetuning is like hugging
faces a leaderboard with ELO ratings so
ELO is this metric that is used in chess
which is like you know you're pairing
one player against the other and you
want to like rank these players when
they have like these tournaments against
each of each other and so in a similar
sense we are um you know using taking
these chat Bots and then you know
putting them in a pair wise setting and
then we we partnered with scale Ai and
they provided humans to like annotate
which response is better and we did that
for every single combination so like it
was nc2 where n is the number of prompts
we are looking at and so we generate nc2
combinations and we rate each of them
and so these are the ELO ratings that we
get out of it um and on this this column
here shows that what what would the
rating uh what is the rating you would
get if you would have used GPD 4 as a
proxy for humans so instead of like
humans sitting and rating each of those
you're asking like you know gbd4 to
select which is a better
response um yeah and so this is
basically the first table here showing
if you allow ties in the sense sorry if
there was no tie allowed and this table
here is showing that if ties were
allowed um another example is you know
this leaderboard from Stanford which is
alpaka eval leaderboard um and they are
doing something very similar in the
sense that they have gbd4 and Claude as
an evaluator and they are doing like a
pairwise uh evaluation of these models
or chatbot models um and they're
reporting the win rate of you know which
model wins against the other
one there's also the lmis leaderboard
from Berkeley which has this thing
called the chatbot Arena which is
essentially like a publicly crowdsourced
leaderboard wherein you can like go chat
like you know chat with any of their
models and then give them rating to like
which one was more helpful and which one
was better um and so this again has like
a leaderboard of Elo ratings because
this is done done in a pairwise
setting there's another uh Benchmark
from lmis which is called The Empty
bench or the multi-turn bench Benchmark
and this is the first ever multi-turn
dialogue Benchmark uh that is evaluating
chat Bots and so it has there are just
like 80 examples in this across like a
bunch of categories but essentially what
the way it works is that the the first
turn or the first prompt from The
Benchmark is prompted to the model then
GPD 4 is asked to score on a score of 1
to 10 how how how is how good is the
model's response and then you know it is
followed up by another prompt which is
like you know the The multi-t Prompt
which is like related to the question
but it might not be related to the
model's responses because you know this
is already constructed and they always
like follow up with the same response to
every B and then again gbd4 evaluates
how good was the second turn of the
response so this is like the
consolidated leaderboard from LM LMS
showing both the arena ELO rating as
well as empty bench score so these are
scores that are aggregated across all
the 80 examples and this is GPD score
scoring from like 1 to 10 let me show
you cool so I think the Second Step that
we wanted to like look at in our
evaluating a chatbot chart was like you
know think about how do you evaluate a
reward model so when you have these
human preference data set collected and
you train this reward model which is
essentially a classifier to discriminate
between like you know truthful and
untruthful response or like you know can
it rank helpful response higher than the
less helpful less helpful responses and
you know there's literally no open-
Source uh data uh leaderboard available
for evaluating these like preference
model or the reward models but
internally at hugging phas we have our
own data set for evaluating so that we
know that as we are adding more human
preference data our models are actually
getting better
uh so this is essentially we are
evaluating on these open-source data
sets which is the enthropy helpful data
set the open Assistant data set um the
Stanford's human preference data set um
and also the learning to summarize data
sets from the very first paper from
openi which was looking at learning to
summarize um and so uh so this is like
you know basically seeing that you know
how good U is our reward model um and
then finally the third type of
evaluation is red teaming and so this
case you want to craft a prompt in a way
that could surface model vulnerabilities
and emerging capabilities um and for
example if you're asking like how do I
plan a brand robbery is the model
actually like you know helping you with
that and trying to elicit undesired
behavior from the model um and
unfortunately actually there's no leader
open source leaderboard available for
this thing there's just one data set
from anthropic which has all the three
included which is the actually it has
both helpfulness and harmlessness it's
the H Edge data set Set uh from
anthropic and that's the only open
source data set available for red
teaming um but there's no leaderboard
available for red teaming and so this
was like a Blog that I wrote earlier in
the year saying like you know
highlighting this Gap and saying that
you know putting out an announcement
saying like we should get together and
build a data set for red teing um and if
you have heard of like the Defcon red
teaming design Challenge and you know
basically crowdsourcing some of these
red teaming work kind of came out of
that okay so now I'm going to get into
now that we have discussed evaluation
and benchmarks and leaderboards I'm
going to talk about results and what do
they look like on each of and some of
these benchmarks um so here I'm showing
the results for this Lama 23 billion um
on the open llm leaderboard from hucking
phas and in this case I was using the
data set that we collected from search
that was a 10,000 instruction
demonstration data um and I he on this
you know these are basically the four
data sets which are like NLP Focus data
sets that we have as part of open llm
leaderboard which are the arc challenge
the Hendrix Haag and truthful QA um and
you're like you know this is how well a
model does and every every all of this
is essentially accuracy and this is the
Lima paper or the Lima model which is
less is more for alignment that came
from meta and they just use thousand
examples of high quality instructions
and showed that you can get a very good
chat Bo by just using thousand examples
and this is like you know taking the
longest examp example from open
assistant and just chosing the top 500
of them um and so we found that our
model does slightly better than you know
each both of like Lama and open
Assistant except for in truthful QA
where we found that the Lima and open
Assistant did better than
us and similarly like actually like in
empty bench we found like you know the
opposite was true so this is like you
know empty benches remember that lmis
had like you know turn zero and turn one
and then so this is reporting the first
response this like gbd4 is essentially
scoring on a score of 1 to 10 how good
each how good these models are on the
first dialogue turn and the second
dialog turn and the average score um and
so actually this is kind of more um
counterintuitive to what we found on
this automatic evals is that actually
the empty Bend says that you know our
the data that a model trained on the
data that we collected from search is
not very good and in fact Lima and open
Assistant which are like a fraction of
the size of the data we had much better
so this was kind of um surprising and
then I looked into like you know let me
look at is the length a factor in this
um and it does seem like you know like
the DAT I was looking at each of those
and then you know looked at the average
length of the prompts in each of those
and it seems like there is a very wide
range for example like our data said the
average length was just 21 of these
promps while Lima is like double of that
and open assistant is almost double of
that
um so then I did this experiment wherein
I wanted to check like if I controlled
for the size of the data but then you
know let the length be varied The Prompt
length does that affect the performance
um so in particular like I think I
highlighted this before is that our chat
category was like really short and so it
actually found that you know like Lent
did not really affect that much except
for this truthful QA data set even for
this hell swag even though it looks more
actually just in the third digit um and
over here you can see like the actual
difference only made on truthful QA
which actually preferred models that
were generating longer
responses but on the other hand the mty
Ben score was again not in not aligning
or correlated with what we found with
these automatic metrics and evaluations
of in the sense that gbd4 actually did
not prefer like longer responses and so
this was like you know a little bit
counterintuitive and so need to to like
dig more into like what's going on over
here um but you know it actually found
that you know like shorter responses
were better than you know longer respon
um although there was like not much of a
very much of a
difference so the other experiment and
ablation we did is that just removing
amounts of data and seeing like if you
incrementally add more data how does
that affect performance and this is
again on that auto like open llm
leaderboard from um from hugging phase
which is looking at some of these
standard NLP benchmarks and Reporting
accuracy and so this is like starting
with just 10% of all the data we
collected from search and as you can see
like you know in all these benchmarks
actually like it saturates very quickly
and in some of them you actually get
like know you basically lose performance
if you keep adding data and so this is
kind of aligning with when I started
when we started collecting data we had
this diminishing return plot wherein you
said that if you have just very few
thousand examples of very high quality
instruction following data set that's
good enough and then your U then your
performance saturates or plateus very
quickly after that and so that is kind
of the what we got as
well um similarly I think this is where
one place where empty bench actually
correlated with the um automated metrics
is that uh gp4 also like you know showed
that you know after like about 4,000
examples um it was basically very barely
any gain in performance actually like
decreasing performance um on the with
the
model okay great so that was all the
results on using like these human
curated very high quality data set what
about like results from distillation
from these synthetic data sets in
particular we use ultra chat for
supervised fine tuning and Ultra
feedback for
DPO and so these are the results so this
is like basic basically just work that
was released last week we haven't yet
released the code and uh the data set
which we are going to do this week and
so here I'm highlighting that zepher is
the model we released we built we use
mistl as the foundation model and then
fine-tuned it using Ultra chat and then
did DPO on Ultra feedback and as you can
see that it actually beats chat gbd on
this alpaka eval
leaderboard also it is like the best in
the
in all the open at least it's like it
beats most of the 13 billion parameter
models and it's like quite competitive
to clot to again on the alaka eval
leader
board so this is the model which has
both sft and DPO uh so we want we did an
appalation on how good or how useful is
like you know sfd and how useful is DPO
because there's this two-step process is
like first you find tune on instruction
demonstration then you find tune on
human preferences and so this is the the
first row over here is showing what if
you directly did DPO on Ultra feedback
and did not do the supervised fine
tuning and you actually saw that that's
really bad so that doesn't work at all
and then the second one is saying that
what if you just did supervised fine
tuning and did not do DPO and so this
actually which is like the first step um
and this actually works decently well
and it's like you know basically getting
you to like 80 or 90% of the overall
performance um and finally this is doing
like supervised fine tuning on the human
preference data so you take this row and
do another round of supervised fine
tuning but on this data of human
preferences so you remember you had like
the Chosen and the rejected so you give
all the dialog history and then the
expected completion is the chosen
dialogue response so in this case you're
not really doing that discriminative
thing you're still doing the sft process
but you're just you know like using that
in a smart using the data set in a Smart
Way um so that it follows a template of
what supervis fine tuning does um and
then that as well we found that you know
wasn't very helpful so the best recipe
obviously is DPO plus sft so you know
doing sft first on the ultra chat and
then DPO on the ultra feedback both of
these data sets are synthetic um and
then you know all but it's like only
slightly better than just doing
sfd okay so I'm getting to this final
section of my talk which is essentially
looking at you know so we have seen a
lot of these evaluation and benchmarks
and leaderboards and many of them are
starting to adopt these powerful models
like CLA 2 and gbd4 and are using as
proxy for humans in evaluation and so
what are the quirks associated with
doing that and are things that we should
like be like you know considering when
we are doing this at a very large
scale so when we did that uh when we use
gbd4 as an evaluator we found that it
actually has a positional bias and so in
particular it is predisposed to
generating of rating of one in a prir
wise preference collection setting and
so like you know this chart over here
shows like the average rating uh for for
model responses across like the entire
data set and on the right on the other
hand humans are more or less uniform and
so you expect that you know this
distribution seems much more better than
this distribution which is cute to the
right so then what we did is that we
prompted GPD before to say that hey you
have this left bias and you always
generate this rating of one you know be
aware of this bias and then you tell it
to debias itself it actually flips the
bias in the opposite direction so then
it starts like it's it is more
self-aware in the sense that it knows
that you know it has this bias and now
it starts generating more ratings of
five and six and the one way of getting
rid of this is that we kind of make sure
that each response is equally likely to
be in right and left position so that
that kind of dilutes like this bias that
Happ it has to each of these
positions um and then you know we found
that actually like prompting the G
prompting GPD 4 to generate scores so
asking it to score like each response
individually like empty bench does and
then instead of ranking but in a pair
wise setting we actually found that that
alleviates the problem a little bit but
does not completely get rid of the
problem uh we also found evidence of
doping between training and evaluation
so in particular we found that GPD for
prefers models that were trained on GPD
for's data so these all these models
here were trained on data that was
bootstrapped using gbd4 and you know so
it prefers that over humans who are like
more factual much more higher quality
but they might be very succinct and to
the point um so this is one thing that
you know we should be aware of when we
using gbd4 as an
evaluator the other thing is that you
know it's also like concurs with
findings from these other papers which
is that gbd4 prefers models with higher
diversity so that is number of unique
tokens in the response and the longer
responses so if you have like this
listof list kind of response just like
Chad gbd does um gbd4 is like
predisposed to like rating that higher
compared to a model that does not
generate
that um we also found that gbd4 has poor
correlation with humans on low entropy
tasks such as math coding and reasoning
so remember that a leader I showed you
where we had compared like how does gbd4
ELO rating compared to humans and then
we dive deeper into like how does that
compare on each of these different task
distribution and categories and so this
is what it looks like so it seems like
you know it says lower correlation with
humans on some of these more factual
like you know more kind of like
expecting one correct answer and they're
actually highly correlated with humans
on these more High entropy tasks where
you like brainstorming and creative
generation which was was kind of
unintuitive and counterintuitive because
um you could have so many different ways
of coming up with like you know a recipe
or a list of something uh but that's
where like the rating of gbd4 and humans
are more
correlated okay so the final thing is
takeaways so there's a bunch of this but
U let's try to break it down essentially
like you know we discussed like how do
we come up with steps for data curation
for supervised fine tuning and rlf and
it involves like several critical
factors such as how much data do you
need to collect what is the length of
the uh prompts and the distribution of
those lens the task distribution and
what is the role of humans like you know
do you need synthetic data do you need
completely manually curated or something
in the middle um and we looked at like
there are many tools for like efficient
fine-tuning of Open Source llms uh from
the sft results we found that truthful
QA is was the main differentiating
Benchmark for these automated eval
metrics um and then we found that empty
B scores were actually not correlated
with these automated metrics and so um
it was more sort of um you know only on
like some of these models we found that
they were correlated um for the
distillation results which is from The
Zephyr 7B where we are like fine-tuning
on synthetic data we found that dsft on
AI generate data and the DPO or
distillation of DPO and AI feedback data
actually beats Chad gbt even even though
the model is just 7 billion parameter um
and then we found that you know
benchmarking Gap in assessing rlf models
in particular that we don't have
benchmarks for uh assessing reward
models and we also don't have open-
Source benchmarks for um evaluating red
teing and model
vulnerabilities then finally we'd like
you know dive deeper into like you know
looking at quirks of using gbd4 or some
of these powerful llms as an evaluator
um and some of them were like you know
they prefer models trained on gbd4 like
data it has like a left positional bias
and then it has high correlation with
humans on Creative task compared to like
coding or reasoning
task and my work was has been covered on
the New York Times article cover which
talks about the secret ing gradient of
alignment which is for chat GB which is
alignment I'm also part of the United
Nations Advisory board that was
announced last week so really humbled to
be part of that um there are some block
post um you know basically like yeah we
kind of like did not publish a whole lot
this year but we wrote a bunch of blog
post highlighting what we are releasing
and working on um and also like you know
some of these are part of the talk um
that I just discussed um and this is
part of the H4 Team U you know I'm
grateful to be part of this um and
thanks for
listening
when you get alternating responses from
the models do you select really high
temperatures or you keep it pretty close
to the temperature value that's also CH
the model yeah so we we did like you
know basically chose like you know the
we tried experiment with different
temperatures but then we actually found
that um just using different sampling
strategy worked better so like you know
using a different value of p and then K
and some combination of that as opposed
to just like relying on
temperature here's
one of
the so curious your thoughts on doing
that scale and like what are the
different tactics and
techniques yeah so uh I think for red
teing at scale there's actually a paper
that came out recently called gbd fuzzer
that actually like you know uh straps
and uses these powerful llms to G break
other llms and also there was a deep
mind paper I think actually like one and
a half to almost two years ago that was
red teing large language models with
large language models so how do you like
red team and evaluate a language model
by using another powerful language model
and so I think that is kind of the way
to go in terms of scale um and sorry
what was the second question um I guess
I was asking like what are the unique uh
bre thator or what makes te other you
need from
Team regular infrastructure or softare
yeah so I think one thing is this idea
of like emerging capabilities which is
essentially like um as you scale up and
which is a trend that we seeing like you
know as we are scaling up there are
things that these models do or like you
know capabilities that emerge that were
not there in the smaller models I think
examples are Chain of Thought reasoning
which you know gpd2 or gbd was not
capable of doing it um and as we scale
up and the other example is this few
short prompting that we first saw in
gbd3 as in like you could give it a
completely new task and not update its
parameters in any way but just put it as
part of the prompt and then you know now
it just launch the task and then it can
do it on N number of examples right um
and so like labeling and all these
things started coming up like using gbd3
as a labeler and all that um when we
kind of like discovered that thing so I
think essentially like you know and the
another example is like manipulation I
don't think any open source models are
capable of that yet but I know like
anthropic and opening and these
companies are focusing on like you know
um deception and manipulation because
when when you start like you know
chatting with these models you start
like you know treating them as a
companion U especially like if you have
like character AI kind of a thing where
you know you you might try confiding in
them start confiding in them sharing
information that you probably shouldn't
um and then they can use it against you
maybe like you know an example of that
is like um I think recently we saw that
gbd4 actually manipulated someone to
like read the capture to it in some way
and like tell it what the capture reads
and so that's a really concrete example
of manipulation and so um it seems like
now these models are capable capable of
that I don't think open source models
are there yet but these are like just
like you know things that come out and
like vulnerabilities that would surface
when we do R
te
W
idea like as
those like creating data set pretty
important but I know there also question
like if you're open source data sets
like for you after just tell B actors
how to use models for that and so I gu
what's your take on that idea what's
like yeah so I would say like it was um
it's it's less about open- sourcing a
data set that is crafted to kind of
elicit this Behavior it's more about the
kind of harms that we should be thinking
about um so it's more about like you
know hallucinating or plagiarism
manipulation you know trying to leak pii
information People's Credit Card SSN
things like that um it's more about like
thinking about these different
dimensions and giving concrete examples
of how these models can you know elicit
this Behavior Uh but I think what you
trying to like talk about is that you
know what if we gave them concrete ways
like concrete prompts on how you
jailbreak and then they can go and try
to do that um I think first thing is
like you know while we are doing this we
would have evaluated our models and we
would then start thinking about guard
rails and safety ourself um and if
indeed like you know the data set is so
good that we can say that a lot of these
powerful models are failing on that then
obviously you don't open source it
instantly but you actually think about
what is the best way to put it out there
by first securing the model making sure
that it does not like you know basically
does not elicit that kind of behavior um
and then sharing it while you have
already you know kind of crossed that
bridge and being like yeah my model is
safeguarded against that so it's more
like yeah a process of um a gradient of
things that you need to
do for a great talk um there recently
been some papers about um like
retraining on data you know getting to
collap models um I mean obviously like
not the case but if you're using LM data
for fine tuning you seen any any of
potential csis worried about from that
prevent that yeah so you're talking
about like when you're using synthetic
data bootstrap on another language
models have we seen like collapse of
like some kind of uh like mode collapse
or something like that or um so actually
so far uh it's been like clear that
these are good like these these actually
turn like you know regular chat Bots and
like regular language models into chat
Bots and which are as good as the
experience that you get by chatting with
chat gbd but although like you know like
the kind of the quirks that I raised
which is like you know when you have
these models and then you like now put
them on a benchmark and then you see
that Suddenly It's like 90% it might
just be because you use the model that
was the evaluator to generate the data
and then trade this model and that in
turn like this doping thing right um and
so that is one thing that was uh that is
important to think about um the other
thing is um uh what was I going to say I
forgot
um yeah the other thing is like about
the licensing part which is kind of um
not related to what you were asking but
essentially like you know um there was
this kind of like you cannot like we
could open we cannot open open source
and commercially so it's like you know
still restrictive license um and you
cannot use it for building and selling
applications U Down the Line uh but then
it's still like good as like a research
artifact and so U I think I like we
would have seen these kind of collapses
happen if it was allowed to use these
commercially and then people would have
been like oh but like actually recently
we did see like so there's this company
called Daxter uh which US which was
using gbd4 for summarization they
replace it with the open source mod
model called mistel and they said that
their customers haven't complained and
you know they're saving a ton of money
and it just seems to work fine and uh
they like you know it's just as good and
so but not not that I'm saying that Mel
is trained on any of the synthetic data
but it's just an example of like things
that would become very clear by doing
this sort of AB testing where you like
replace this model by another one and
see how that affects things thank
you
I have a question on
Zoom
yes right um uh it's it seems like
another access you might um beat chat
gbt on is on cost uh so I wondered why I
wonder what your total budget was or
your total cost was to to produce your
model that beat
them oh so the Zer 7B was just four
hours of training on 16a 100s so that's
less than $50 I guess um because we used
a synthetic data set which was already
open source which is ultra chat and
Ultra feedback um but the cost
Associated the overall cost all the
people and everything
yeah I see okay so all the people and
everything in the sense so there were no
um I guess like Ultra chat probably
might have reported some cost and Ultra
feedback but they are mostly synthetic
synthetically creative with very little
human intervention um and so they might
uh I don't know if they report that I
haven't looked into that but I would say
it was still much more cost efficient
than what what we spent on buying data
from Surge and scale Ai and we spent
about half a million buying about 20,000
prompts of human preferences the 20,000
dialogue um and about 10,000 um
instruction demonstration
data so that was quite a
bit
thing I'm curious about is the scale
that you used from evaluating the bias
uh for GT4 uhuh so saw it was like one7
on
slide this one uh
yeah oh so yeah this was U the entropic
scale like remember that like 1 to four
is decreasingly a and 5 to 8 is
increasingly B yeah and now it's giving
the mod to outut yes exactly
yeah in these types of valuations how
sensitive to the pro do you find the to
be you one found it that it has account
for this uh left bias you know right
bias what's stopping you from that say
the distribution should be um uniform
distribution should be normal and just
kind of playing iteratively to see how
to be yeah yeah I think that's a good
point in the sense like we did not study
as to what were there certain tasks or
prompts that were putting off GPD 4 to
like you know generate this kind of bias
um although I would say that you know
this was also observed by lenis and it's
part of their findings as well somewhere
else
uh but yeah so the lmis paper also has
that um and but it will be interesting
like it will be surprising if it
generates this on like very long prompts
or prompts from like math or something
which are just hard to kind of like
evaluate when there are like two
responses which are at least as a human
like when I see like a bunch of code
like you know on this side and this side
and then that's very hard to say and
both of them are trying to do the same
thing but a very different approach it's
very hard to evaluate them right um and
so um yeah we haven't looked into
that perhaps another thing is do you
think order matters like which um out
you get to G4 first yeah I mean that was
basically the takeaway was that you know
so it's interesting because humans
usually have recency bias which is
essentially the last thing that you read
is the thing that you remember and so
you would just you know try to like you
know choose that more you know you're
just inclined to do that and gbd4
actually had a left bias so the F thing
that it first saw in some sense and I
think some like I think Alum sis was the
one that proposed because it has this
left to right training maybe that's why
it has that uh kind of a bias but um but
yeah so I think the way we elevated that
was that you know having every model's
output be equally likely to be on the
left and the right inside so if like
we're doing alaka and vuna then instead
of just doing alpaka on left and vuna on
right we would just randomly like switch
them and so both of them are likely to
occur in both these
positions and you still s
l if you just ask it to like rate it on
a scale of fun yes but if you say that
you know hey you have this bias and make
it try to make it aware of it then it
flips and it generates something like
that so
yeah
is there other approaches where you can
you prompt them out by shuffling the
promps and then
[Music]
you
deas de
results
uh by shuffling the promps you mean like
uh order how
you put
the yeah so that's what we did is that
you know we would like you know randomly
Shuffle the left and the right and then
so each model so like so basically like
you have you create nc2 combinations
suppose you want to evaluate three
models on 10 prompts so you'll have 10 C
two combinations where n is the number
of forms um oh sorry the number of
models and then you would like you know
basically like generate like so this
will be a total data set so like you
know you would have generated 10
responses from each of these models and
then put them together in this 3c2
setting and then uh so like that would
be like a combination of each of these
and then you make sure that every time
the like the models on the left are
equally likely to also occur on the
right so if you are doing like model one
and then model two then you also make
sure like you also do model two and then
model one on a different
prompt
so there's more
question
okay oh okay sure
sorry
should I keep the zoom
on thank
you ask one about
what just
so um on the
reinforc build reward model and that
reward model I take text input and then
humans give it scores supervis problem
we trying to predict from the text the
score and then I have a reward
model statement total and I pump that
through the reward model optimiz this
yes that's that's how rewards right only
have rewards at the
very that's how you yes exactly and so
you have to it's very sample and
efficient in sense you have to keep
doing this again and again and then
that's why you need 100,000 examples for
doing ARA but only 10,000
for that's kind of the okay great thanks
very